[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the dave ramsey show and it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i'm ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
which is part of the ramsey
solutions network and i'm joined by my
colleague
ramsey personality bestselling author
host of the chris hogan show
on the ramsey solutions network and it's
always fun when you and i
get together in the dave ramsey show
sandbox we're gonna have some fun today
big fella oh i agree my friend we are
gonna get a chance to
give some people some real practical
guidance on their careers
uh but we're also gonna talk about that
wallet ken we're gonna talk about what
you have to do in this new year
because we can't talk 2020 is gone
thankfully yes
thank you for reminding me it's gone and
so i have caught myself saying you know
this year and
all the things 2021 is here we have new
opportunities
ahead all right so here's what we're
gonna do uh one of the things we're
gonna throw out there is some of you out
there
are are listening and you're going okay
i'm working the baby steps ken and chris
i'm working it i'm getting there but i
sure could use a bigger shovel
um as dave likes to call it and that's
more income
and there is a myth for some of you who
have wandered over to the ken coleman
show
where we talk about doing what you were
created to do in your work
is the dream job of reality the answer
of course is yes
but people go uh can i can i work the
baby steps
can i make steps towards the dream job
while paying off debt and the answer is
unequivocally yes absolutely so i want
to throw that out there we're going to
talk about your
life your money we're talking about your
work but for those of you that are right
now going okay
i'd like to make some more money i'd
like to actually get promoted make some
more money which means i can get out of
debt
and save faster faster yes well we're
gonna talk about that so that phone call
that's welcome you got money questions
you got life questions
chris and i are here for you here's how
you jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's toll free number
triple eight eight two
five five two two five remember this is
your show america we're gonna start it
off in st louis missouri
where joe awaits joe how can we help
hey gentlemen wonderful to speak to you
uh my question is in regards to
hsa investing i've done it with my
company for like
four years now and each year they max
out our hsa
um and i really haven't used a ton of it
so i've got about
18 grand in there oh that's good
sitting there not doing a ton for me i'm
not sure if i can really
how to invest it i've talked to the bank
that um holds the money and
their only options are cds i wasn't sure
if there's another way to go about that
yeah you should be able i mean in
looking at this you know you would want
to look at it
just like you would your 401k funds so
you're looking to be able to utilize
those inside of growth stock mutual
funds
um and so the cds we don't want that
those are certificates of depreciation
uh those things it's not gonna grow it's
not gonna give you any growth you got a
good chunk of money there
uh so that's what i do uh i want you to
reach out to your do you have an
investment professional that you're
using
i do okay take your form in and take the
information
about your hsa and get connected with
them and start to walk that through
uh you know typically banks will do that
proprietary thing and that's push
their stuff uh but the last thing you
want to do now do you already have an
emergency fund in place
yeah debt-free beside uh the house okay
i'm not doing a free
year okay that's good that's good and so
here's what you do you go sit down with
your investment professional get that
money put into the gross stock mutual
funds
and now that when you know hey this
money is going to be growing for me and
if we need it
we use it if we don't we don't all right
all right wonderful there it is hey yeah
thank you and i really appreciate him
reaching out because ken a lot of people
they say man i've
had this money coming out of my paycheck
into the hsa month after month
but if you haven't used it what is it
well it can become
like your medical emergency fund that's
right right and so you think about that
so you set that money aside and if
you're investing it and you don't need
it it's going to continue to grow for
you just like your 401k
yeah very good i like that the medical
emergency fund and don't you know
as two dudes who have three kids each
those medical emergencies are
absolutely waiting to happen oh they
happen now you're a whole lot older than
me but
oh but it happens you know that is what
we call fake news
folks that is fake news but you know
it's like i i don't know how much money
i put into the coffers of the boyne and
the bone and joint institute locally oh
yeah well between that
grocery stores goodness gracious yeah i
like the medical
emergency fund that's really really good
triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to somerville south carolina
jacob 15 year old jacob joins us chris
jacob how can we help
all right well right now i'm only 15 but
i have like 3 000 in savings i'm trying
to figure out to make more money because
i make like
7 000 right now from a part-time job all
right
all right that's nice how many hours a
week are you working or how many hours
over the course of a month because i
know you're in school
i work like 18 in a week because that's
the max i can work right now
look at you yeah jacob what do you do
i do work at a like a restaurant near me
that is fantastic
yeah do you mind if i ask you what your
hourly uh rate is
yeah i make minimum wage which is 750 in
this state what is it
750. 750. okay so here so here's the so
jacob make sure i understand the
question you're looking for some ideas
on how you can make more money because
right now
you're maxed out at your 18 hours per
week so
the the the uh theoretical answer jacob
and chris is he needs to get a better
job meaning he's going to get a bump
from 750 but he's also 15. that's right
so
it's like where does he find that i
would look towards manual labor jobs
you know what like maybe in construction
and things like that in the trades
where they're going to be willing to pay
more money than a restaurant will i
would start there
i talked to your parents i talked to
everybody you know to say hey
i'm looking for a manual labor job um
that pays more than 750 an hour somebody
who needs a young man who's going to
come bust it
18 hours a week and then the other thing
is
is that you know i i'd also consider
you know is there anything you can do
that's not so much manual labor but is
there any kind of data entry
or some things like that that are
computer-based if you're comfortable
on a computer where companies again are
looking they would pay an adult
yeah they paid to do some of that hey
jacob i'm curious
what mo what are you saving for buddy
i'm sure now saving for a car okay how
much are
you needing in your mind to buy a car
how much you looking to spend
like ten thousand ten thousand how much
do you have saved
three thousand all right and you wanna
get this car by win
i'm trying to get it by the end of this
year see i like this see we got a goal
we got a time frame and we got a number
hey uh jacob quick question on the 18
hours i understand that's what the legal
limit is if you're working for so but
who's keeping you from going out and
and and poop or or you know raking
leaves and cutting lawns that's your own
business right
i collars a lot in the summer yeah
winter right now so my point is is
you'll find something find something you
can work for yourself
as well yeah because you're not bound by
that you know you can go out there and
work for neighbors and friends and
anybody possible
and they're throwing cash your way my
man so that would be another
uh idea for you yeah i am very proud of
you young man seriously i mean at 15
years old
you're motivated you're you have a goal
and you got a time frame
so many people jacob will say hey i want
to do x y or z
but they don't know when they want to do
it by yeah and so you have in that time
frame i like ken's idea get out and
hustle
let people know that you're looking and
just be very smart
there's all kinds of crazy out there
that wants your money jacob let me tell
you the story you laughing when i said
scoop and poop but i read a story on my
show two years ago of a young man who
bought a fishing boat
twelve thousand dollar fishing boat by
walking around his neighborhood going
his neighbor's going look do you got
dogs
i'll come by once a week and scoop up
all the doggy doo
and they were painting cash man and that
guy
bought himself something scooping some
doggy doo
i like that i want to know what he did
where there's a will there's a way
don't move more dave ramsey show coming
right up
[Music]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues from our
ramsay solutions world
headquarters in nashville so excited
that you are joining us today
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
chris hogan as we take you through
the show today it is about your life
that means your money your work are you
stuck in your career you can't figure
out how to make more
money uh you got some relationship stuff
you want to talk about around that money
stuff because money
creates tension it just does we're going
to take your call
we are here for you triple eight eight
two five five
two two five let's go to chicago
illinois next where stephen joins us
stephen how can we help
yeah how's it going guys we are having a
blast what's going on with you
yeah so i was calling because i'm a bit
of a situation
this year because uh well i just turned
29 and um
i only have my associate's degree right
now and i have a note that then i saved
up about 20
000. and i'm not sure what to do next
i'm thinking about uh
either buying a condo or going back to
college and finishing my four-year
degree and i was just calling to ask you
guys on your opinion all right so here's
here's what i always ask when somebody
asks me
chris uh and stephen about should i go
to college
so there are two qualifications is it
the only way
stephen to get where you want to go
professionally
is it the best way if the answer
is no and no then no don't go to college
but if the answer is yes
on one of those then yeah i think it's
the right move is it the
only way automatically yes is it the
best way
yes it is so the question becomes
are you considering college because you
know
beyond a shadow of a doubt that it is
the
only way or the best way to get you
qualified to do what you want to do
what's the answer
um i guess i didn't think about like
like that the only thing is the job that
i have right now i'm really not
planning to be there for a while so
that's why i was thinking about college
okay but here's the deal i i'm fine with
you realizing in fact i'm glad you've
realized
that the job you're in right now is not
where you want to be because i'm the guy
that says hey
what is it that you were created to do
in your work we can talk through that if
we need to but the reality is is that
you got better things to do with that
twenty thousand dollars my colleague
here can give you lots of good ideas
but until we know stephen that
again college is the only way or the
best way to get that ticket that
qualification to do what you really want
to do then hold off on it
and now once you find out that you knew
do need a college degree
then yes sir we want to go through that
uh chris thoughts on that
he needs to be patient yeah stephen i
agree ken and and i love that ken
walked you through that because stephen
you what you don't want to do is go to
college because you're bored
yeah or go because you think that's the
natural next step
so let me ask you this what what what do
you have any other debt
that you owe right now um
no i i took out a loan on my 401k but uh
it's being paid off as as i work to it
it's only like ten thousand dollars
the one hair i have on my head is
wiggling and it's standing straight up
listen to me don't you pull any more
money out of that 401k
don't do it okay because here's the deal
if you lose or leave that job that money
becomes due and payable
immediately within 60 to 90 days so
don't have that headache in your life
anymore
so i want you to get intentional get
that thing out of your life and then
don't go backwards there
but what i want you to do is really
start to think like ken's book ken you
ought to be
generous and give this man a copy you
finish
well i'm going right now but the reason
why i say that is
uh stephen ken's book is literally going
to get you thinking more in depth about
your heart
and what gets you excited and i'm
telling you it's going to pave the way
for you to start understanding what you
can do right now
and that's the thing so don't don't
spend that money on college it's just
out of hand
let's put him to the test stephen here
this i do this on the ken coleman show
all the time
all right stephen you ready here we go i
want you to answer with your heart not
your head you ready
all right what would you do tomorrow if
i guaranteed you
that you could not fail but you didn't
have to commit the next 30 years of your
working life to it it was a big fun
professional adventure what would you
try tomorrow if i guaranteed you
great money and great success what would
you try
um i will be a
personal trainer oh make good money wait
a second now
hold on stephen do you need a college
degree to be a successful personal
trainer
um no let me answer it for you sure
about that no no i
i'm sure you need a certain amount and
so in the state of illinois here's your
homeworker sign before we go to bed
tonight i want you to find out
what are the state certifications or
requirements for you to be
a personal trainer and if it's not a
state thing what are other gyms
what's the national kind of what's the
bar stephen that's what we're focused on
man
that's what we're focused on is becoming
qualified to become a personal trainer
and we're going to give you a copy of my
book the proximity principle because
the proximity principle says in order
for stephen to become a personal trainer
he's got to be around
people who are personal trainers and
he's got to be in places where
personal trainers are hanging out and
where personal training is happening
making connections and learning the the
lay of the land if you will stephen uh
that's what you need to do now i'm
bringing this back around to that 20
grand sitting in the account because
chris
what does he need to do with that 20
grand knowing that
he's got a well he's got a 401k loan
he's got it first and foremost got to
get that paid back
so 10 grand right away so it's a matter
of trying to talk with your company
some of those 401k loans will not allow
you to pay back in a lump
so you need to contact talk to your hr
person and find out what the plan is and
how you can start to pay that back
and then get that thing paid back but
then build up your emergency fund
so coleman says this all the time
stephen and
is the primary job you're in right now
may not be your forever job
but it's the one that's going to get you
closer to the one you want yeah the day
job
is think of it think of your day job as
the platform
right the diving board by which you're
eventually going to jump into that dream
job and
and and we've got to understand many
times so he's in a situation where he he
knows it's
it's a dead-end situation he don't want
to go but he's got it and he's got he's
got it and he's bringing in money right
and so he's going to have to figure out
paying off that loan and then he goes
all right i still got some cash left
over i can tell you this he's going to
have plenty left over
to be able to get qualified certified as
a personal trainer now what he does is
he goes all right i'm gonna get
qualified so i've got that in my back
pocket
now i'm out there using the proximity
principle and i'm making connections to
where somebody goes
oh hey uh steven's a great guy and we
need a trainer over here
and he starts doing or he might find
that i want to do it myself
and so he's going to do it as a side
hustle he's still got the day job
that's the thing he's doing to 20 hours
a week training and he
starts pocketing that cat that's right
it's not that he had to put it on hold
and couldn't do it
okay ask me the questions you asked him
again
what were the three questions you asked
what would you do
if you had if money go so what would you
do all right
if if if you knew you could not fail i
guaranteed you
financial and professional success okay
and so it's this fun
adventure but you don't have to commit
to it the rest of your life right that
unlocks people's brains because
everybody's afraid of making that
is it the right is it the right dream
job right you know is that that kind of
thing it's like whoa
whoa i didn't ask you that i said what
would you try tomorrow
if you got the money you needed right
and you knew you couldn't fail and you
didn't have to commit to it the rest of
your life it takes off all and you know
what it does
yeah you saw how quickly he goes from
locked up to oh man i mean you put it
that way it'd be a personal trainer
that's the answer yeah ding ding ding so
what's happening there
is when i asked the question that way
chris we're turning people's brains off
and we're allowing their heart to answer
the question and see the brain is there
to protect us
right sometimes it's well that's fair
yeah but in this situation our brain is
if we feel any fear or doubt what does
our brain do oh yeah
absolutely it's protected it's closed
off so i have to remove the fear and the
doubt and that silly question
it's a silly question it is but it
removes the fear and doubt for a moment
and we just go oh well
if you take away all of my risk and all
of my doubt oh my god well then i do
this right well there's your answer
all right well i answered mine what is
it i put radio host speaker and author
chris i've got great news for you what's
up uh you're in your sweet spot that's
good
you were you sir that is your dream job
and i couldn't i couldn't be more proud
of you
i appreciate that on the commercial
break i'm gonna sign a book for you
but listen people i i'm serious ken's
book proximity principle it
lays this out and it is not just for
young people
it's for any person that you look up and
you go is this where i want to be
yeah and so grab a copy of ken's book
again proximity principle go to
kencoleman.com
pick it up at kencole.com you can get
all three
formats chris cause i'm a man of the
people you get all three formats for one
price that's the ebook
the hard copy with my signature i did
picture yeah and my voice isn't as it's
deep as yours but it is quite melodious
so they can get the audio book as well
all three formats one price
ken coleman.com thanks to papa dave hey
uh
don't move folks we're just getting
warmed up the dave ramsey show continues
right after this
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the dave ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague chris hogan as we
answer your questions about life your
work
your money triple a 825-5225 is the
toll-free number to jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five chris
uh one of the things you and i both know
is homeowners insurance can be one of
those things that
you set it and forget it because when
you bought your first home you may have
just gone with whatever
coverage your lender suggested at the
time you haven't thought about it twice
since but just because checking up on
your insurance is
easy to forget doesn't mean that you can
afford to smart homeowners
shop coverage every two to three years
to make sure that they still have the
best coverage
for the best price you also want to make
sure that you have the right amount of
coverage on your home if it's gone up in
value
if it's been a while since you've
checked your insurance we want you to
talk to one of our endorsed local
provider insurance
agents our agents will find the right
coverage for your needs and
if they can get you a better deal than
what you're currently paying they will
text the word home to 33789 that's
home text that word to 33 789 talk with
one of our trusted insurance
professionals
about the right coverage for you again
text the word home to three
three seven eight nine triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to jump in on the conversation
with chris and i
and we're gonna go to oklahoma city
oklahoma where amanda
is on the line amanda how can we help hi
i am wondering if i should refinance my
home
so we just purchased our home we built
it um
in may of last year and we got an
interest rate of 3.5 percent
at a 30-year fixed and we're trying to
figure out because current interest
rates are a lot cheaper right now for
about 2.5 percent and we're trying to
figure out if we should
refinance for 2.5 on a 30-year or if we
should pay off the rest of our debt and
then
refinance for a 15-year
all right so tell me this what's your
household income about 240.
okay and what other debts do you all
have right now
um it's a total of about 33 000 and we
have
about 12 000 still left in student loans
about 3 000 left on a credit card we
have about 10 000 on a car
and about 8 000 on a personal loan
okay got you you guys have you had this
240 income for a while
um well sort of yeah i mean
we've had it for about uh two to three
years
um we we really just got i i got a new
position and i got
on a big dave ramsey cake and i've been
binge listening on your podcast
no that's good and the reason why i say
that is because
your income you guys have a strong
income yeah i know it's ridiculous
and what you don't want to have are
these little things that suck away from
it
amanda and the credit card the car and
the personal loan
those are all signs to be a people that
are maybe above their their living
or were financing life before it
increased does that make sense
okay all right no and i and we sat down
and we were both like i don't know where
this is all going this is ridiculous we
have to fix this
and so that's what the biggest motivator
is and we already have our emergency
fund of
you know our thousand dollars and we've
already paid off over ten thousand
dollars in credit card debt and so
because we put a lot of our house when
we built our house on credit cards and
has already paid off oh
okay so you were using credit cards for
the building of home okay well
some of it yes we already we put over 20
percent down on our house
and we did pay cash for that okay great
and so instead of financing a lot of
like
lighting and everything into the
mortgage we just put it on the credit
card and then we just paid it off
that way we wouldn't finance it over 30
years we just did a short temporary
finance on the credit card and then paid
it off okay
well in answering your question and
taking a look at kind of where you guys
are
uh being able to go from a three and a
half interest rate to two and a half is
great
but guess what term i want you to do at
15 years
yeah seriously uh because as you do this
and i know i
you amanda you are a smart gal you and i
know the most obvious difference between
a 30 and 15 is 15 years
but it's the hundreds of thousands in
interest that the
tens of thousands that it saves you so
you guys looking at your budget
tightening it down go ahead and get a
quote on that 15 year
i love the fact that you're doing it
because again you got a rate of change
of one percent or more
i'm never going to have you refi just a
refi but being able to change your rate
that low and shifting to a 15 it can be
a game changer for you all
right thank you so much for the call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to san diego california
where heather joins us heather how can
we help
hey um i have i'm kind of in a
predicament
hey heather heather we're having a hard
time hearing you let's see if we can get
you to move that phone closer to your
mouth let's try that again
is that any better not really i'll tell
you what let's look back
yeah try's back i'm gonna give you back
to zach there he'll help you out we'll
see if we can get you a better
connection
uh yahudah is in baltimore
maryland how can we help hey
ken hey chris how's it going we are
having a blast what's going on with you
sir
so first of all ken huge fan proximity
principal
literally the playbook of my life oh
awesome my wife too
thank you chris you helped me keep the
vision so i love you guys and i
appreciate everything you're doing
well i appreciate it thank you i'm
currently
uh in the personal uh personal
uh the financial coaching master
training right now with uh ramsey
solutions and it is out of this world
out of this world and i met with a
couple last night
and this guy he's a real estate agent
and he does a little investing and
flipping houses
and he uses a credit card for his
business and he understands
oh don't get into debt not a good thing
and they're
building their way up but i want to give
him a good solid explanation
as to why not why why to not use a
credit card
for business because he says oh well i'm
spending all that money at home people
anyways
it's just wood it's not like i'm
spending you know more money groceries
at the stores
totally different thing and i feel like
i have sort of an answer but
i really want to get you know what i
appreciate this and i i like that you're
asking the question
here's the reality at the end of the day
he is going to do whatever it is he
wants to do
and and that's his choice but here's
what the reality is
96 of people don't pay off their credit
cards each month
okay 96 percent and so that's the next
thing
it's and again having done the largest
study of millionaires ever been never
been done talking over 10 000
they don't use them so it's not a habit
or a tool of people who are trying to
build true wealth
it's more of the habit of people that
are trying to live want to be rich
and so here's the deal don't try to
convince him
no no no no what you do is state the
facts lay out your reasoning
but let him make his choices he gets to
figure that out it's like people that
want to worship at the fico score
when i figured out exactly what the fico
score represented
i had this aha i went oh this is not an
indication of how well you're doing with
money this
is all about debt right that light bulb
went off for me and when i started to
at first i was trying to hear it i was
trying to make people drink the kool-aid
i really was i was like listen here you
got to listen to me you got to hear me
and the people were just listening
because for 30 or 40 years of their life
they had been worshiping at the fico
score like i had been doing prior to
being
converted to seeing the reality so
here's what we got to do
give people the grace and the space to
walk their walk
what we're going to do is speak truth
but he doesn't have to get rid of his
credit card to be able to listen to your
principles
he doesn't have to cut it up that day
but i'm going to tell you when you plant
that seed and you keep watering it
and watering it and telling people about
the truth they'll eventually start to
hear you and he'll have his own epiphany
one day
absolutely and thank you uh for uh being
in in financial coach master training
you got to love it when we we meet these
men and women who are he's just calling
me i'm just totally brown-nosing with
you coleman
what proximity principle is the playbook
for my life
goodness gracious that's brown nosing it
is effective
okay because i am receiving that
compliment
it's a great question i am receiving it
because i think it's a darn
good book that's a great book if you
don't know how to get where you want to
go
go get it daveramsey.com kencolma.com
the proximity principle
all right fun stuff there you know it's
interesting that
i love that i love the heart of that
because you know we have a lot of people
listen to the show where obviously
they they started listening for personal
reasons right i want to get my money
life i want a financial piece
and so they they start walking through
the baby steps and maybe they become
coordinators or maybe they go to the
next step
and and go to our training to be a
financial coach
and they call and they kind of go hey
what do we say here on this because
we've told them everything we've learned
we told them everything you guys say on
the dave ramsey show
but they're just not quite getting it
it's really fun to see that passion and
conviction but you make a very good
point listen
don't beat people over the head with it
just keep sharing the truth that's right
showing the love
shining the light and when they're ready
and when they need it most
they'll get them that's right so don't
get all hung up on it just keep being
who you're being all right we're gonna
keep doing what we do and being
who we are and that's gonna continue
here on the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the dave ramsey show
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
chris hogan
and we are here taking your questions
about life money
working on purpose getting that bigger
shovel so you can get out of debt faster
and save money faster
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number to jump in it is
your show america
triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to san diego
california where heather is joining us
heather how can we help
hey so i um i have a predicament with my
car
i you know i had a new car regrettedly
my last car was totaled and i'm about to
lose it
um it's i'm like four months behind and
i think the only reason why it hasn't
been recoded is because
they can't find me because i'm out of
town okay
um i'm not sure what to do because the
cali blue book says
that i would get for private sale i'd
get about 2 500
less than what i owe on it how much do
you owe on this car
a little under 16 000 okay and tell me
this
why are you four months behind what
happened
uh i haven't been able to
get regular i'm a photographer in
san diego i've been in san diego i
actually live in a different state but
i've been in san diego
since august okay we're on lockdown so
i haven't been allowed to work okay all
right so
here's here's the reality heather of
what's got to happen
you have got to reach out to this
creditor and you've got to communicate
okay because right now what you're
feeling is like you're feeling like a
hostage
you you you're feeling like you're on
the run like bonnie and clyde or
something listen
contact them if you're four months
behind yeah they are they are looking
for it
because even if you can't pay you can
pay attention
let me say that again even if you can't
afford to make a payment
you can pay attention get on the phone
right now with that creditor
contact them let them know the situation
of what's happened
you're not the only one okay that's been
in lockdown or hadn't been able to find
some work
but i want you to communicate this with
them so they can document the account
and now instead of being opposite
opposing each other
you can get on the same side of the
table and work with them to figure out
how to resolve this car situation and so
if you can't make the payment they're
going to need the vehicle
here's the thing i want you to work with
them to either a
get it sold or for you to voluntarily
voluntarily turn it in but we got to
talk about what's going to happen with
the deficiency balance
and what i mean by that is if you owe
just over 16
they're gonna sell it at an auction for
five then they're going to come after
you for 11.
so communicate with them ask them to
document the account and gain agreement
on the plan of action i'm going to add
one other thing to that
uh and that is heather the next phone
call you make after what chris just told
you to do
you start calling everybody you know
yeah and if you can't take pictures
right now
i get that but just because you can't do
your main line of work because of the
coveted restrictions in california
doesn't mean that you cannot work
and i know it's not fun and i'm not
judging you but i am
challenging you that you need to get to
work and and when you make that phone
call you need to say look here's what's
happened
but i am now going to do one two three
jobs
and i'm gonna work out something with
you all but they got to know
that you're actually going to make an
effort to get this thing right sized
and the way you do that is by getting to
work i don't care if you've got a
nanny if you've got to deliver pizzas uh
you got to drive
delivery anywhere and and everywhere you
can my point is
get some money coming in it's right even
if it's not anywhere close to
photography
uh you need some momentum in your life
well ken what happens is as i tell
people once you start making some money
a you're going to feel better about
yourself that's right
and it's always easier to find another
job when you got one
that's the truth yeah so absolutely
heather call them today seriously don't
don't hide anymore
and just own it when you call them you
say listen
right out of the gate i want to
apologize uh i have not communicated
well with you all
i dropped the ball i'm sorry and what
you do is you kind of just take
take that off the table so you're not
having to feel that and now you can
start to
communicate with them about what to do
that's right sarah is up next
in portland oregon sarah how can we help
hi thanks so much for taking my call you
bet what's going on
um so i'm kind of gonna i don't know
how you would classify this but i'm i'm
uh
29 i'm single no kids not married and
i am i guess i'm between baby step four
and five
great i do about 20 in retirement
um no debt and i just
i i have a question about saving so uh
a few like future things that i've been
thinking about is i'd love to buy a
house someday
um right now i my rent is pretty cheap
and i live with friends so
i'm done enjoying that so i would like
to say for a house
um i have about my car's paid off i have
about
maybe five years left on that car before
it
completely dies um so i want to start
saving for a car
and then um kind of leap of faith but
i'm not dating anyone but would love to
start saving for a wedding someday
so my question is how do you kind of
save for multiple things do you put it
all in one account do you
that's a good question well what it is
is you're goal oriented which is
fantastic
now i want you to apologize to your
vehicle okay don't you put that evil on
your car and tell it
it's only got five years left your car
hurts you okay your car hurts you
uh but here's i love your
goal-orientedness uh what i would do is
this
back down you're investing to 15 okay
the additional five percent i want you
to put it over into your money market
account where your emergency fund money
is sitting
and what you're going to do you know how
much in there is the emergency fund
right and then you start adding to that
and inside of that as you put that money
in you're saving for home down payment
or car repair whichever happens first
but the main thing is is you've got
money in there so you can do it in one
account there's no reason to open up
five or six different money market
accounts
just have your regular one you know that
x amount in there is the emergency fund
the amount over that
is for home down payment uh car wedding
etc
yeah i love that you love it she's on
top of a great job but yeah back that
retirement down back that retirement
investing down
that's going to help you make progress
for saving for a house uh yeah she's a
goal-oriented young lady she's making
stuff happen
yeah yeah she's really great she's not
waiting yeah i love that
that's good i really like that because
you know it's interesting though
you see what you said about the car you
know what i mean well you don't know
that that car is gonna die in five years
yeah don't put that on your care of it i
think what she meant to say was
i think i'm gonna break up with this car
that's that's right that's what it is
i think five more years i might want to
break up with this car
you know it's not you it's me i said
that for about eight years and kept
driving the car
you know why because i didn't want to
part ways with the money
i just wanted to keep going yeah yeah
it's really easy to hang on to that oh
it is and you can talk
good and i duct taped that car and drove
it like a skateboard if i had to but i
wasn't going to
part with that money i just i but
finally i had to oh
it's so funny it is fun i love it you
know what
here's what's interesting on that that
the big savings goals
so so what people need to understand is
you've got that big savings account that
money market account it's called a
spreadsheet
you don't have to have multiple accounts
just go in and go here i know what my
emergency fund is
and then okay i'm gonna start saving for
the car and i'm gonna put x amount of
money and so i'm keeping tabs with that
and so i got a handy little spreadsheet
and it just very easily
shows me how much is in there and what
it's and what it's for
yeah no you really can and it's a good
simplified way just to be in control
um and it's it's great it you can do
this uh you really truly can
and i want to encourage people out there
i had a little lady roll up on me once
cannon told me
chris hogan you and dave ramsey don't
want anybody to have no stuff
she had attitude ken she really did and
i i thought she was cute as a button and
i said no ma'am that's not true
i said here i want you to have nice
stuff i just don't want stuff to have
you yeah
and when you have stuff and it's
attached to debt it's the stuff that has
you
so have nice things but save up pay cash
for it
we got to get in that habit you know if
by paying cash for small medium and
large things
yeah you know and and part of that deal
is is is there is it's agonizing
it's agonizing to save because
you you've got your eye on something
that you desire
think about it there's a lot of emotion
attached to a big ticket item that
you're saving for
so it plays games with us think about
this the psychological and the emotional
because you go
oh my gosh i'm really really excited
about this i really really want this and
i see everybody else
goes into debt for this and they got it
right now i gotta wait
this long it's gonna take me this long
to be disciplined and safe
and there's where we get in trouble
that's right so it's like you gotta
understand
that what you're the battle you're going
in to save
it's a battle and it's with your
emotions it is always worth it it's
totally worth it
absolutely hey i want to thank our
producer james child
and our associate preacher kelly daniel
but most of all my good pal chris hogan
and you
america thank you for joining us this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show and it's
where america hangs out to have a
conversation
about your life your money
your work whatever you want to talk
about
because all those things are all kind of
tied together
i'm ken coleman host of the ken coleman
show on the ramsey
solutions network joined by my colleague
chris hogan who's host of the chris
hogan show
also part of the ramsey solutions
network and we are here
for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number to
jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five and and
chris i know that anytime we get a
chance to do this
with dave or together uh you know we
walk away going beats working for a
living oh my gosh
i mean to get a chance to reach out and
help people yeah i mean
this is i mean coleman you talk about
all the time the sweet spot
and dream jobs i mean i'm i'm living it
yeah we're both there
yeah and uh so what a perfect call to
start off this hour with i mean these
are the kind of fun
questions here chris is in the
tri-cities area of our great state of
tennessee
chris how can we help hey guys thanks
for taking my call
uh i've got a kind of good problem i
guess you'd say to have
uh i live on a pretty pretty regular
budget and have for years
and at the end of the month i've usually
got anywhere from 500 to 1200
extra after expenses after bills
spending money
golfing everything all right and my
question is
what i've been doing i just got into
investing right about the start of the
pandemic
last march to be honest i opened up a
wealthfront
etf robo advisor account just a toy with
it to start with
see how it worked put just a little bit
of my savings in it like three thousand
dollars
and since i've been adding to it and my
question is
what i've been doing is putting about a
third each month a third of what i have
to say
in that account and the rest just in my
regular savings account
and i'm not sure if i should be putting
more being more aggressive and putting
more in the investment account
or if that's a good formula if i should
just stick with what what i'm doing now
right you know if i should put more in
my savings account less in the
investment account okay so answer this
for me my friend how much is your your
household income per month
uh i clear i clear about four thousand
dollars a month
okay all right it's just me i'm saying
single single okay
all right i have very little debt all
right what debt do you have left
i have a small mortgage on my condo like
450
a month okay i have a new car payment
the only
first and only new car i've ever bought
my life but i felt like i was in
position i could do it how much you owe
on that how much do you owe on that car
uh i still i mean i just bought it last
year so i still
you know i'm making payments on it it's
i still owe i guess
yeah 25 30 000 okay all right what else
and i have a student loan payment of
about 200 a month all right and you owe
how much on the student loan
uh i just started those
about a year or two ago also okay 25 000
on those
all right well chris here's why i'm
saying this what we have found is when
you try to do
six or seven things at the same time you
end up being ineffective in all of them
and so what we have figured out is when
you zero in and you focus on something
you can make some stuff happen so i love
that you budget
number one that means you're very
intentional with your money you said you
have anywhere between 500 and 1200 left
over per month
here's what i want you to invest in your
financial future
and what i mean by that is i instead of
you investing right now
i would rather you pause that and turn
your attention to the threat that's in
your life
and that's the debt you have okay i
would tell you to get intentional
like the car payment how much is that
payment per month
that's four hundred dollars all right so
400 and you got about two how much going
to the student loans
uh 200. all right so i would tell you
to take that 500 to 1200 that you have
extra
and target the the debt you have i'd
knock out the the
you said the student loan you owe about
25 000 on
yeah and then about 30 on the car i
would attack every i'd pick the minimum
payment on the car
every other free dime brother i'm gonna
send toward that student loan debt
knock that out of your life that's gonna
free up 200 now take all the extra pay
it toward the car
you'll have the student loan debt out of
your life you'll have the car paid off
then what i would tell you to do is once
that's out of your life i want you to
build up a serious emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses once
you have that done
now you can start to invest here's the
best tool
go with 15 of your household income from
an investing standpoint
okay you'll have the debt out of your
life you're gonna have a pile of money
as a cushion for you
then the only thing you're gonna owe on
is your condo or your townhouse
and then you're investing 15 percent
you're gonna be in an outstanding
position young man
yeah i i thought you're very nice about
the car
well i mean it's done what's done is
done now
could i tell him if you're getting
intentional and if he was telling me
things were tight
could i tell him to sell it if he wants
to be gazelle intense yeah he could slap
him for sale sign on that thing get out
of his life
and go find a datsun 280z oh i love
those
1984. those are those are vintage
and by the way vintage is back well
vintage is back hold on because i want
to come to your vehicle
but but when you get serious about
getting out of debt
and especially from a man chris what i
think is you start to see that student
loan debt get out of your life then you
go wait a minute i'm voluntarily holding
on to this car loan yeah i could sell
this car go find a beater car
and then remove that 450 obligation
that's what happens in phase two of
people getting intense
yeah and with a car that's that new
that's worth a decent amount of money
you can get it moved he can move that
and then actually pay cash for something
else okay so
tips on how to sell a car because i know
some people out there
did some silly go to kbb.com figure out
how much you could sell it for right you
want to see that dollar amount
contact the bank or the company you have
the loan through
get your 30 day payoff on that loan so
you look at what it's worth look at the
30 day payoff
then you can try to price this thing and
get it get it sold
you want to be proactive use online
things to sell your cars people will
look
people will travel to come by your car
so you want to get it out there take
some good pictures of it get it all
detailed
shined up looking good take pictures get
those things posted you can use
all kinds of things online craigslist
facebook marketplace
all these things but but be proactive
because there are people out there with
cash that'll buy it that's exactly right
by the way when you take those pictures
make sure that you don't post the
picture with your license plate on there
you know just a little thing there you
gotta be careful these days oh good to
know you know you just a little a little
marker or whatever you want to do or
i've seen people literally take a
picture of the back of the vehicle
and they got their like finger in the
picture yeah it's kind of creative
it is and here's the other thing you
know what's even more important tip
when you sell it take your license plate
off of it
yeah right okay because i've heard some
horror stories of people that forgot to
do that
the person continues to drive it if they
get a ticket or something
they can come after you yeah chris i got
to tell you
brother i think you you a guy who lived
below your means you knock this dead out
and you're a guy that can knock it out
quickly you can always go back and get
the really nice car
uh but but man to your point getting the
risk out of your life it's just
so important get it out walk like this
it's like crazy
you know there's three things you don't
want in your life kim i'm gonna tell you
this okay we go to break i'm gonna do it
fast i like it you don't want crazy in
your life no
you don't want drama in your life and
you don't want debt in your life
delete them all three crazy drama debt
bye i'll tell you what you do want more
of in your life
great conversation a little more coleman
a little more hogan yes
a little more of the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know health care has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same driving
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman
he is chris hogan and we are here for
you triple eight eight two five five
two two five you got a question we'll
dive into it we're not scared
no nope hope is on the other end
of the line triple eight eight two five
five two two five how many of you out
there
are miserable in your work but you think
you can't change jobs because you're
trying to get out of debt
i got news for you call me
chris and i'll talk you through it you
can stay on the baby steps
continue to get out of debt moving
towards financial peace
and still change jobs in fact for many
of you you need to change jobs because
you make more money and make that shovel
bigger and get out of debt faster
i want to remind folks that every time i
have ever
either facilitated a debt free screen
when we're co-hosting with dave or we're
hosting
together or i've sat there and watched
screams debt-free screams
every time their income has gone up have
you noticed that
when dave always you know we walk
through okay how much we make into the
start of the journey yeah how much
you're making now
and there's always a sizable
or we can say significant income
increase now you and i
both know why and it's a it's a function
of focus it really is
you start looking and you start calling
and trying to get yourself out of debt
you'll start thinking differently you'll
start perceiving things differently and
you're
open to trying and it's amazing when you
start to get certain areas of your life
in order things happen
now hear me just because you make more
doesn't mean you're going to do more get
more progress
here you need a system yeah and speaking
of system if you never feel like you can
never save enough or you can't pay off
all your debt
after a year like 2020 most of america
feels the exact same way
but the money shouldn't be the one thing
you have to worry about that's why in
2021 we are hitting
reset that's right because no matter
what's happening in the world
you can control your money you just need
the plan like i was talking about
earlier
ramsay plus is our step-by-step plan
that helps you get quick wins
so you can make real progress real fast
because once you get all your debt paid
off guess what your money gets to stay
with you
in your bank account that means you can
finally start spending and saving your
money
without worry and get the security that
you need
right now so here's our challenge to you
decide on a total money reset this year
then start ramsey plus real simple
commit to working hard in the first 90
days
and watch those small daily wins turn
into lifelong habits
and you'll never feel out of control
with your money again so here's what you
do
to start your ramsay plus for free and
it is free people
go to daveramsey.com again that's
daveramsey.comreset
and you can get on a plan today don't
think you can't
because you can you just need to try
it's time to go make the move you'll
never regret it triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to athens georgia where derek joins
us derek how can we help
hey how you doing we are living the
dream what's going on
here i got a quick question it's kind of
from my life um
she's about she's no debt she's got
about two
220 k saved up she's 38 she'll be
retiring in two years we're having her
first baby
uh so at 40 you know she won't be
working she'll be spending
all day full-time on kind of deal by
that time she'll have 450 500 saved up
like i said we have no debt so my
question is
i'm starting to get a little older and
i'm wondering with her money and her
income and everything
she'll have saved up at that point um
what ideas do you have to wear where to
put that money safely
you know in case something happens to me
um
first of all i don't i don't really
believe in the stock market and all that
stuff uh
just kind of what other ideas you got
out of the box as far as that goes
you know chris before you dive into that
i i he's saying something very
interesting i've picked up on it derek i
just need a little bit
more uh light shed on the situation you
keep calling it
her money her money if it's
what do you mean where's the hour money
part i'm a little confused why you're
calling it her money
well we have separate we we don't miss
our monies
why well i mean to be blatantly honest
when we met
um i had a lot more than her and i still
do and i don't want her to feel like
that she
that's she's dependent on that i told
her you know you i'll help you make
yours
and what yours is yours obviously you
know i paid for everything
i've just been uh i wouldn't want to
have that you know
so derek how long have you all been
married
uh we've been together almost six years
been there at about two
okay and you all have kids
no the first baby's on the way first
baby okay
first baby's on the way all right so
well in two years
yeah okay all right well here's the deal
uh go ahead coleman i feel you twitching
over here
no no no no man i'm not listening we're
not i'm not gonna beat up on you but
but but we believe that that it's your
money
that both of you as a unified couple
should have a unified bank account and
i'm not i'm not here to
attack you know your reasoning behind
that uh but you know i never want her to
feel like she was dependent on me well i
think you've made your point i think
she's done a good job but
i think it's time for we i mean chris
you're the one that always says we need
to speak
speak prince french speak french eric
i've never been to france but i know how
to speak it and it's we
speak don't don't say me speak we and
here's why i say this
uh you obviously care about this lady um
she's getting ready to be the mother of
your kids
and that mindset of you working hard and
your
work ethic and your diligence you want
to kind of pull that together and have
that full-on
mental process of you guys working
together as a team
and i can tell about the sound of your
voice you grew up playing sports didn't
you
yeah what was your favorite sport
uh football and i'm a big golfer but
football was mine when i was able to
what what side of the ball do you play
offense or defense
i like defense what's up much simpler
you just tackle the man with the ball
yeah i hear your brother we're cut from
the same cloth he likes running to score
i love hitting people yeah but here's
the thing i want you to tackle this life
stuff
together with her yeah and i think
working together on your finances and
you know it sounds like you may have
been burned at some point in time or or
had something happen
financially and working together as a
team you're going to get to where you
want to go a lot faster now real quick i
want to shift on that
and you guys may need to do some
marriage counseling on this you know
before you have a kid so you can find
out what is that thing that's blocking
you
and marriage counseling is not a bad
thing or therapy is not a negative it's
a help it's a fine tuner
but you said something else i want to
hit on you said you don't believe in the
stock market
yeah why well i'm gonna say
just real quick when i retired um i
talked to my stock market buddy and he
said won't you go in there and ask the
guy what he's worth
and you tell them what you're worth and
what sense does it make to give a guy
worth a hundred thousand dollars a
million dollars no i agree
i agree and so it's not about the market
that's about an
individual so what i understand that
but i'm a physical asset guy like me i
know if i put 400 000
in the property that property is there
that property value is going to go up
nothing's going to happen to it but i
don't know if i give like anybody money
where it's going to be by 9 o'clock
tonight it may be in japan and
at the bottom line i don't trust other
people with my money okay now that's
where we're heading
on and that's a real that's a real thing
that's real and i will also i've got to
ask you derek
do you and i'm i mean this do you trust
your wife
i'm 100 okay listen i understand the
question
all right listen to me but because i
think you're a guy who doesn't give
trust easily and i don't think that's a
negative my man
you're a man of principles to get it yes
sir i get it
but listen to me brother the amount of
money that she's got the amount of the
money that you guys got
if you put it together yeah and you do
it chris chris take over these mutual
funds and
your smart investing my man listen to me
you got to loosen up a little bit you're
going to thank us for it
well and the reason i'm asking you about
that is i think you know
it is a matter of working with an
individual that's going to help you grow
that money
uh you can be a physical asset guy you
can but you and i both know
a physical asset is only worth what
somebody's willing to pay for it
right you can have a property and you
can say hey i'm going to list this thing
for sale at 450.
if it's in a terrible area or it's a bad
property it's not going to sell
so you in the mindset of diversification
i like the mindset of you obviously if
you're going to buy real estate my
thought is you only want to do it with
cash
uh first and foremost uh you you i don't
want you taking on mortgages and all
that other stuff you're gonna invest you
do it with cash
the other side of it is diversify
yourself derek
listen put some of that money in some
gross stock mutual funds
i'm not talking about buying bitcoin and
and and crypto grump tree
you're all that old crazy stuff no put
it in gross stock mutual funds this way
this money is going to work for you
i know you work hard to make this money
make your money work do me a favor
get in connection with the smart
investor pro have a conversation
lay out your dreams and goals and let's
see what they can do for you interview
them
how much are they managing don't look at
their personal salary
what have they done make them show you
the scoreboard you're a scoreboard guy i
like that
the man you got to learn to trust but do
homework trust and verify
hey don't move more of your calls coming
up this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman ramsay personality
host of the ken coleman show on ramsay
network joined by
fellow ramsey personality chris hogan
and
host of the chris hogan show a part of
the ramsey network
as well hey you need to find out
yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
okay so today's question comes from john
in kentucky
he says my wife and i are debt free and
work for a non-profit
we are paid a base salary of about 30
000
and have a 401k with our company we are
reimbursed for housing and
transportation
roughly around 20 000. should we be
putting 15 percent of our base pay
the 30 000 into the 401k or
15 of the total the 50 000.
so okay great question john here's the
reality
the 20 000 that you guys are getting in
the transportation and housing
is income that's going to count as
income so what you want to do is
invest 15 on that total dollar amount of
the 50 000 the 30 000 in base pay plus
the 20 000 in the transportation and
housing reimbursement
do 15 000 of the excuse me 15
of your household income is what you
guys want to be saving for retirement
now listen uh a lot of people out there
have questions on retirement
questions on investing here's what i
want you to do i want you to go to
chrishogan360.com
you can click on the dream team button
and once you hit that button you can
locate a smart fester pro that's in your
area
i want you to interview them find
somebody you trust that you believe in
and they can help you they can review
your 401k they can take a look
you can get an endorsed local provider
to help you with your insurance
you can get a tax elp to help you with
taxes because tax season is coming up
the goal is is don't go it alone you
definitely want to get a professional in
your corner
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five we have a few phone
lines still open you can get in
let's go to jimmy in anchorage alaska
jimmy how can we help
hey guys long time listener first time
caller
great um i super appreciate you guys i
just love you i hate debt and uh i teach
it to all my employees
that's awesome good for you yes how can
we help at a young age
um so young age my dad's company was
going under
he was making about 800 a thousand
dollars a month
with expenses going through the roof um
and then he let me
take over and work for him every day and
uh together well
with with mostly me i and most of our my
decisions
i grew the company into making anywhere
from 150
to uh to 80 000 a month wow
wow oh every month time and time again
and uh
with that since i was about 14 i uh
we grew that company and we just
completed a 30 plex um
and debt free 100 um
and uh now we're at a point where um my
dad has been promising me the company
and for the last 18 years doing this
and we're at a point where um i bought
the property across the street from the
30-plex just because i thought there
might be an issue
and personally um and i have about 175
000 debt on it
i'm doing the bi-weekly payments 15-year
loan can't stress that enough to anybody
listening it's amazing
um but uh we're at a fork on the road
where um
my dad has kept promising me the company
all these years
and for the first time i can say you
keep promising it
but if you want my signature to
complete the 30 plex because we ran into
a problem building the 30 plex and he
needs to take over my property across
the street
i'm asking him to put me on the deed of
the property because this property is in
his personal name not in the
corporation's name
and i'm also not on the corporation
itself
because he has a problem with greed
unfortunately
hmm i'm kind of yeah i'm kind of at a
point where
do i walk away or
do i give him the signature and then
walk away
or do i just keep hoping and delaying
the 30 class
um until because this is the first delay
you know if i don't sign by
by monday um which is a delay of 30 days
which is 30 000
a month potentially but yeah
i'm just i'm going to be honest we did
do dave ish over the years
um however most of my purchases are 25
to 30
000 and i do put them on credit card but
i do have a credit card account that can
pay off
the limit of the credit card every
single month and i replenish that
every time i pay off the credit card and
i
because of my industry i have 18 months
of savings
in the corporation because um because we
work in tourism every year you never
know if you're gonna have a major
problem
right and my banker told me 12 years ago
saying if you
um if you if there's no fish in the
water
you can't uh make any money and same
with tourism if there's no one
coming to a lab hey jimmy jimmy jimmy we
got a lot of details here uh
but let me i'm really nervous no you're
doing great listen
we're trying to help you we got limited
time so i want to ask a point question
yep you gave us i think i heard three
scenarios in there
a lot of details around those what do
you think you want to do
before chris and i weigh in before you
called you were leaning a direction
there's nobody
that i've met like you who doesn't have
an idea what they want to do
and you want chris and i to weigh in on
that option and i want to know where
your
gut's at because there's some tension
between you and your dad and one of
those options i can tell you should be
off the table
uh and that is delaying this thing
because he's waiting for a signature
that's going to create
more tension if i'm understanding this
uh well uh what are you leaning towards
doing before you call
yeah i i don't want to walk away i mean
i've sunk uh
you know 18 years since i was 14. i
don't want to walk away i didn't think
so either
so what do you really want if you could
wave a pencil a magic pencil in the air
and solve this thing
what would you want to be the conclusion
all i want is to be on the deed
so i have guaranteed to have no
no more arm am i going to am i going to
get the things i was promised
or not all i want is the promise and
i've already had this discussion
and it it did not end well and we've had
a discussion with other people
with the family members the trusted cpas
the lawyers you know everything and he's
just like
he hasn't earned it yet okay so that was
just like that was my next question
i know what you want but you've already
floated this and dad's saying no so now
we got ourselves a game of chicken
mm-hmm yeah you really do and jimmy you
know as you look at this one of the
things i really want to
caution you on is you know anytime you
mix
money and family things can get tense
uh you without a shadow of a doubt from
what you've told me
and told us you've got a lot of sweat
equity into this thing
you have grown it you have approached it
uh that like it was your own business
and with the mindset of the promise that
you were told
the thing that i realized is that if
it's not in writing it's not real
and i i think you know for you i
i want to encourage you to do a couple
of things uh is to
try to remove as much emotion from it as
you can
initially looking at the business side
but also thinking about hey
what is your out because what you don't
want to do is feel like a hostage
right you you you wanna and so and talk
what do you think your dad's hang up is
if he's saying you haven't earned it
you said he's greedy is he greedy or is
he needy
does he not do well with money so he's
got to have this
yeah he doesn't he he the wrong joke is
don't tell me
when he makes a purchase it's the ryan
joke of the company
if i can cover it it's just it just
annoys me when he doesn't make a planned
calculated decision what happens i love
i respect money
hey jimmy we gotta answer this quick
what happens if if
you um you play poker on this and you
don't sign
or or you you don't do the deal with him
because he won't sign your name on the
deed where is this how's this gonna
affect the company
um it's potentially will go under to be
honest
he doesn't even know how to do anything
in the company he's been retired for
eight years but he doesn't admit
he's been retired okay so he does here's
why he asked that question
you got to understand the stakes you
don't want to walk away
but you also don't want to do this deal
without your name being on the d
but you got to decide if if my dad
doubles down and he has no idea how bad
things could get was what you just said
you could unintentionally
submarine sabotage the very thing that
you want to keep
this may be one of those where you punt
and figure out which battle is worth
fighting right now this is not an easy
answer no
it's not it's not because you got family
involved in the other team members
involved
uh buddy i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna
encourage you to meet up with your
pastor
and get connected so you can get some
guidance think big picture make the
right decision
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
hope is on the other end of a phone call
this is the dave ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
chris hogan as we take your calls about
your life your work your money
you need a bigger shovel all right i'll
talk to you about that i'll teach you
how to get promoted
uh you need some financial peace well
we're gonna tackle those
topics as well as a matter of fact chris
uh we went to break
and uh very very complex call yeah we
really yeah we just had with a young man
uh and you you you weren't done with
that no you got a little something else
you wanted to say yeah
we were talking to jimmy in anchorage
and he's got a he's in the family
business he and his dad
are pushing back and forth right now uh
jimmy wants it to be in writing
that he is going to inherit and be able
to take over the business
as they get ready to do a deal right now
that needs his signature
and what i was telling jimmy and we were
guiding him this is a complex situation
uh you've got the the the young buck the
son
and the old buck right now or are
butting heads
uh kind of fighting over territory and i
think the more important thing for for
everybody in that situation to remember
is
you also have team members that are
working for the company and you got
customers that you serve uh
and there's a mama involved in the
middle of this as well
and probably other family members and so
i i think it's imperative that you all
reach out
uh get connected with your pastor to
begin to sit down and talk about the
true things that are going on
and then begin jimmy to talk about hey
what's the long-range plan
what's the what's going to happen in the
next year to two years
and to talk about what happens if
something happens to your dad
is this something you would inherit and
have that and i think it's just
you need some communication right now
you guys are butting heads
and i don't want you to do make an
emotional decision
that's going to have a ripple effect
inside that family for many years to
come so i just want everyone to take a
deep breath
get connected with your pastor get
connected with somebody that you all
trust a mentor
somebody and sit down and have a
conversation as a group yeah i'm glad
you brought this up
you know the thing that i would share
with our audience because i think there
are other people that are listening
today
that are in some type of a family
struggle there's there's money involved
whatever it is and this would be the
advice
that young man believed deeply in and
what he had done to build the company he
but he believes
deeply in the company itself and and
wants to run it wants to own it
but you know i wish i had had this
thought when he was on the line but
i would have said listen to me don't
lose the war
over the battle and you've got to
sometimes go
what happens if i dig in and i make my
stand right here
right now now there are times where
chris
you you take the stand that's right
there is no
turning back that's right but as i asked
him the question right before we went to
the break i said what happens if you and
dad
don't figure this out and this thing
turns into a stalemate
he goes the company probably goes under
and that's a situation where that's the
last thing he wants it's the last thing
dad wants
and so i would just tell you all that
when you're in these tough emotional
struggles sometimes with people
think about the war step back a little
bit and go what's the
big picture and there are times where
we've got a retreat and
technically maybe we lose the battle or
the battle
is forfeited or it is a tie use whatever
analogy you want to use there
be very very careful uh about sometimes
digging in and taking a mortal
relationship loss yeah and and if
there's other baggage and i know there
is because it's called
family but you know if there are other
issues that are left unresolved or other
things that are
adding to this you don't want that to
add fuel to this now
flame that it it has other people's
lives at stake
that's right so you you guys be
intentional and i'll be be praying for
you but like i said get someone in
um so that can mediate and talk with and
you guys can talk
with each other with the emotions dialed
down all right
let's go to richmond virginia where
debbie joins us debbie how can we help
hi thanks so much for taking my call
this is so exciting
you bet what's going on i i'm calling
about
a question of uh about college money
i have um three kids
one of them is in college and we're cash
flowing and using his
the savings we had for him the second
one is a senior
and um his funds
did his uh education ira did really
really well last year
and i'm a little nervous about keeping
it in an aggressive fund
so my question is should i move it to
like money market or something
more cons you know should i move it okay
you said it did well how much is in
there debbie
um about 40 something thousand okay
if you were to move that 40 to something
much more conservative
is that going to be enough to get the
sec child number two through college
uh yeah okay now and that's the reason
and the reason i ask that is because
right now what it's doing is you've got
it
invested in the way that it's gaining
some growth so
if you're looking to gear that down or
or shift it uh
i i like that idea a lot better than
just moving it out altogether
um now you basic investing
is based on risk tolerance time and your
goal
and so if you all have hit the goal then
what i would do is connect with your
investment professional try to talk
about hey
now we want to go more in preservation
mode we're wanting to preserve what
we've grown
because we've got what we need but the
beauty with the
the the esa is that if you don't use it
all
right if it continues to grow and you
don't use it all you can move that to
child number three
so you've got options you know i just
think the big thing is is
being aware uh a lot of people are
asking me a lot of questions they're
calling into my show the chris hogan
show
asking me about the stock market and
what's going to happen at this and
now that the election is over and this
and this and i'm like listen
this stock market is a living breathing
thing right
if someone hiccups it responds but the
reality is it's a roller coaster ride
it's going to go up it's going to go
down look at what happened pre-pandemic
right we were sailing high we get into
march and all of a sudden now we had a
drastic an incredible drop
but as we hit in september and october
it was back up
and then it was higher than it was back
in february
so that shows the resiliency of the
market that it is real
but the most important thing is
understanding it's going to be that ride
how much of a ride are you looking to
take we have to grow money ken
because this thing called inflation is
real cost of living is going up so
if inflation is hovering between two and
three percent or higher
and you've got your money slapped over
into a savings account getting a quarter
percent
your money is shrinking that's what we
mean by shrinking money
you don't want that you want your money
to grow so we have to invest it the
right way
uh seth writes in on facebook chris and
i get this question a lot
and this is fun i want you to hear this
ken i'm 42 years old
i've worked hard to become debt free i
don't like my job but i feel really
stupid for trying to start a career at
my age my kids are in high school and
their college is funded
my house has paid off as you see how
ridiculous this is getting
yes but i love my guy seth tell me what
to do i want
to love my life but i can't while i'm
stuck in the job i'm in
hey seth you're desperate for permission
i'm giving it to you brother you have
worked hard you're only 42. how about we
say you're 42 years young number one
number two you're financially in great
shape
you don't have to make a risky move
every tell you what's going on this is a
facebook question so i don't have the
luxury
of going back and forth with him but
really diving into the fear here and
here's the fear
the fear is is that he loses all of his
financial worth
that he fails miserably if he tries to
do something different at 42.
wait a second wait a second
that's the wrong narrative the narrative
should be
i'm 42 i'm in great financial shape what
is it that i really want to do
and just let's start with that here's
the answer
bing once we get that answer then we go
what is it going to take for me to get
qualified to do that there's the
experience question and the education
question what do i need to learn
certification
some new degree in some cases uh and
how much is that going to cost me how
long is it going to take the experience
question the education question the
economic question
and the expectation question once you
get the answers to those questions we've
got ourselves
a plan yeah but absent of the knowledge
of those answers those four questions
chris it's scary and he goes
i feel really stupid the other thing is
there's pride going on there because he
doesn't want anybody to go
you got a really nice job guarantee he's
got a nice job he's got a good job
he doesn't want any of his friends and
family to go what are you doing leaving
that
the golden handcuffs and that's pride
we're worried about what other people
think so
therein lies the issue seth call the ken
coleman show let's dive deep on this
we'll get to it hey i want to thank my
colleague chris hogan for hanging out
with me
i want to thank our producer james
childer associate producer kelly daniel
but most of all we want to thank you
america for hanging out with us
and having these all-important
conversations remember
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is
the dave ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money i'm ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show which is
part of the ramsey solutions network
joined by my colleague
chris hogan host of the chris hogan show
i'm part of the ramsey solutions network
and we're thrilled to be here together
taking your calls this hour triple eight
eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five you got some
retirement questions you got some
investing questions you got
some general money questions well we got
chris hogan
right here uh you want to talk a little
bit about that big shovel part of this
deal
you're not happy in your work you're not
making the kind of money you want to
make you want to figure out how to make
that transition and still stay
on the baby steps well i'm your guy
we'll take those questions as well
and hey if you want to dip into a little
bit of the chris hogan show in the ken
coleman show
well we'll take those questions you know
us you know what we do so hey
the point is we're here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five you ready to go big
fella let's do it man i'm excited to see
who we have on the line all right we got
paula
in dayton ohio paula how can we help hi
there
i am a problem child
what does that mean wait a second i'm
not sure i believe that so
what does that mean you haven't heard it
yet
i'm on the edge of my seat okay
i am 52 years old for one and
have never budgeted a day in my life
money was never spoken of in my home
um my mother i had no idea
where money came from it just was
there we just had it and um
got married at 18 stupidly went from my
parents house to
my now ex-husband's house and it was
kind of um if he wanted it it was great
if i wanted it
it was stupid so as you can imagine that
was one of the reasons we got divorced
um 15 years later so um
never knew anything about money still
so then i was on my own and here we are
now
i'm 20 so uh years later and
um i went back to school after the
divorce
and got a degree as a occupational
therapy assistant
and started making some pretty good
money still
no budget you know if i had it in my
pocket i spent it and that kind of stuff
was in debt often and a lot
and then had finally paid off all credit
cards
i owed with a car and a condo
and so that was great and then my mom
got sick
with alzheimer's and i um
went in and helped my father with her
sold my house um i moved in with him
and i thought that i would end up
getting that house because i was the
only one that they had out of
um he had children she had children they
had me
that was not the case so i
um wasn't willing to buy
his house the house that i was going to
get you know and i mean i was going to
inherit this house but he wanted
kind of wanted his cake and eat it too
kind of thing and i was paying all the
bills and
then he wanted me to buy the house so we
he sold the house
and i bought the house that i'm in now
um so long story short i ended up
having three surgeries last year
i broke my foot broke tore my meniscus
tore my wrist hey paul
i i am so sorry about all that but we
have limited time and i know you got a
lot going on
what that's okay what's your question
what's your question for chris and so
here's my question
i have gone from a 58 000
job down to a 20 000 job whoa i
owe yes so um
i my monthly expenses
monthly is 24.88
my bring home pay is 3100.
i have an 18 000 credit card because i
had to use that to live on
while i was off on surgery with you know
to make up
with um workman's comp because they
don't pay very much
i owe 19 000 on my car which
that's included in that 24.88 i have 99
000 on my house for my son and i i have
a 30 year old
son who has autism my father is now 80
who will probably
be moving in with me because he spent
all of his retirement
so is your question so paula what do i
do
i don't have any money left how do i
budget
if you don't have money great news hold
up paula
paula paula
yeah first and foremost you got to take
a deep breath right
and you do have a lot going on but
here's what you can't do
we can't tackle everything all at once
so you're gonna have to take a deep
breath
you've got a lot of stuff in your rear
view mirror but what you have to believe
is you've got much more
in your windshield and what i'm saying
is you can glance back
and look at the things that didn't go
well or that did
or didn't go as planned but now in front
of you you will
have what's called choices and so
realistically what would i do
i'm going to start to think of ways
number one and how to boost my income
like number one to go from 58 000 to 20
is a drastic drop
yes you had some surgeries you had some
life happen that was outside your
control
but we're going to control the
controllables my faith my attitude my
outlook and my actions
and so in that i want you to control
controllables let's begin to take on
extra jobs if you have to
get this car sold and out of your life
so you can eject that payment
and get the boot off your throat and so
it's these kinds of things that you do
you start to take control of things that
you can
you may need to go sit down and talk to
a therapist
to just say you know what i got a lot of
stuff that hadn't gone as planned
help me and that's on the mental side
the mental health side of things
but as far as strategically financially
you got to take control
so i'm going to tell you to get over
into ramsay plus we got a free two-week
trial right now
i want you to go over to see if you are
going to commit to this
because i have figured out paul some
people love
drama some people love it other people
are allergic to it
other people say they've had enough and
so if you've had enough you can get over
in ramsey plus
learn how to budget we're going to show
you with the best budgeting tool on the
planet
it's called every dollar and so it's a
matter of taking this one step at a time
can not try to feel like you can fix
everything all at once yeah you won't be
able to fix it all at once paula but
listen
you've gotta take us up on the ramsay
plus get in there
and start using uh the every dollar
budget
make sure you go through the financial
peace university and walk through this
and as chris said i would
my number one priority right now would
be increasing my income right
so that you can begin to make some
headway and i want you to
start to have some boundaries for
yourself and have real things if things
didn't go as planned with your dad
initially
and now you're talking about he's moving
back in okay well
you said he had kids and previous
marriages got to have a conversation
yeah so i'd probably be pulling the
siblings together so we can talk about
what's going to be done for dad who can
afford to do what
that way you're not having in a silent
bitterness you're getting clarity that's
right but you can do this paula
you just got to take control of what you
can control
make some more income start paying off
that debt you got to sell the car
and drive a hooptie that's fine too
freedom is not as far away as you think
i've seen people pay off way more
than what you've got you can do this we
believe in you
stop using that credit card that's right
get it out of your life
all right folks don't move more of your
calls coming up
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com and take advantage of this
week's
special savings
[Music]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined in studio by my
colleague
chris hogan as we take your calls
about your life your money your work
the relationship issues around money
we'll take it all on triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five i want
some of you out there
may be new to the show i want you to
just picture for a moment
your life with no credit cards or
medical bills no student loans no credit
card
excuse me no car payments let's just
think about that for a second how much
better
would you feel after 2020 most of
america feels the same way you do right
now stressed and out of control but this
year can be different it's time
finally to take control of your money
the best way to do that
is the ramsey plus money reset it's our
challenge for anyone
who wants to start and does start ramsay
plus
this year how much progress could you
make on your money if you went all in
for 90 days
all in to paying off your debt fast and
finally saving for
emergencies with ramsey plus we're going
to show you
how to get daily small wins with your
money and even some really big ones then
we'll help you turn those wins into
lifelong habits
this year is the year you can decide
to reset your money to go all in for 90
days and take control of your money
make today day one and start ramsey plus
for free
dave ramsey dot com slash
reset that's where you go dave ramsey
dot com
slash reset a reset uh you know chris
there's power in just deciding to go you
know what
why not oh yeah i'm just gonna go ahead
yeah
it's you know it's kind of like jumping
in the pool when you know it's like good
grief it's gonna be cold
it's that first spring pool visit and
you know that water's too chilly
you know kids don't care they just ah
they're running like crazy we adults we
get there we go
we get to be our age we we know we know
some things
but you're right you just gotta jump in
though you really do and and i want to
encourage people with this i mean we
talked so much about 2020 and we were
holding our breath
since july waiting for the year to end
and lo and behold it has ended
and so now what and i think a lot of
times if you're not careful
you'll get a continuation of last year
if you don't change some things
and i think it's important to change
your expectations your outlook as well
as your actions so
you know it's just time it's time to
make some decisions it's time to make
some changes
and sometimes the band-aid just has to
come off and so you just got to pull
that thing off and say you know what i'm
changing stuff
now i love it well we've got people
lined up that want to make some positive
change in their life and in their money
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's the number for
you to jump in as well triple eight
eight two five
five two two five modesto california is
where bobby joins us bobby how can we
help
all right thank you for taking my call
how you guys doing man we're having a
blast what's going on with you sir
all right so uh man i'm on baby step
three
uh i paid off all my debts in the last
uh actually i paid it off last year as
crazy as the year was
i got a chance to pay it off it was 33
000 in total there you go
me and my wife you man me and my wife we
stuck to the baby steps and we went
ahead and knocked it out
uh we we also got our six-month
emergency fund
today good i love it i love it yeah man
we really went gazelle intensity and we
just really put our hearts and minds
into it and we got it done
uh my question now is going into the new
year
um you know the stimulus tax tax cut
tax money coming in for jeffery
what do you guys think is the next best
move for me is it to say for a house
is it the put the 15 into investing
how much do i do i save for a house uh
what percentage or not is it a good time
i would be a first time home buyer
uh stuff like that i just uh first being
my wife i'm pretty excited about where
we're at
yeah i just want to touch base with you
guys well you you should be excited
about where you are you all have taken
back control
of your financial life congratulations
you paid off 33 000 in debt
you don't do that by accident and
especially in the year when we had a
pandemic so
i'm very proud of you guys uh you've
been very intentional now
you had multiple questions there for me
bobby so let me tell you this
first and foremost when you're looking
at buying a home you got to be aware of
your landscape
you guys know in california you guys
charge for air
out there i mean it is expensive so you
got to look and figure out what part of
california are you looking to buy
or are you thinking about moving so you
got to be aware of this
and start to understand kind of the
median home prices in your area
and what you're thinking of i'd connect
with a good
real estate elp in your area just to
give you a lay of the land and know
what's going
on the next thing i do if i'm in your
shoes right now i'd start to save for a
home down payment
it sounds like house is something you
guys are going to be intentional with
however if you don't see that being
something that's going to happen in the
next two to three years
then i would definitely say you know
it's baby step 3b
when you save it for a down payment
minimum of 10 percent
is what you want to have i'd prefer you
go in with 20 down but a minimum of 10
and you could just park that money right
in with your money
emergency fund in the money market
account you know if you've got 15 000 in
for your emergency fund
anything over and above that is a part
of your home down payment
that's what i do if it's gonna be two to
three years out
that you gotta say you know what we're
going to rent for a little bit and be
intentional to try to save up money
that's fine too but have a plan yeah
really good advice there thank you so
much for the call and congratulations
you know let's
let's just revisit the fact that in in a
crazy year a pandemic year
he and his wife got debt free fantastic
work that's really good the best
is still ahead for you bobby great stuff
let's go to steve now
in seattle washington steve how can we
help yes i have recently retired i'm 66
years old completely debt free
i have a roth ira and a conventional ira
the roth ira is worth uh
a quarter of a million dollars and the
conventional ira is worth 600
000 dollars in mixed mutual funds
uh the roth is more uh speculative than
the conventional
but what i'm wondering is if i should
consider
backing out all my money into cash and
then dollar cost averaging back
into the market using the ramsey
portfolio models of the 25
in each category uh i want to conserve
my
nest egg but i don't want to get out of
the market completely but i'm thinking
we might be due for a crash here pretty
soon or at least a big adjustment
and i just want to be prepared what's
your opinion well okay steve let me let
me hear if i'm i'm
asking you right the backing back in are
you talking about that from the
uh traditional ira or your roth
both i was thinking okay well here's
what i tell you
you know people typically whenever there
is a new election or
any kind of new year or new season
that's coming people are always trying
to have a magic crystal ball
uh they're always trying to tell us that
a crash is coming or an increase is
coming and here's the thing that i
realized
if we look at what happened in 2020 in
the year of the pandemic
and the market dropped like it did as we
look back in march
and then we look at the climb that it
made back in in october and september
here's the reality nobody can predict
so what i would tell you is is with the
roth money that you have the quarter of
a million you've got that thing
i mean it's after tax you've got that
money growing tax-free i'm not messing
with that
uh looking at your traditional uh you
know you you got to begin to talk
through and look at and say okay
am i at my point have i hit my number
where i want to be
or do i want to continue to keep growing
this like you said preserving the nest
egg but you just don't want to preserve
you're also probably looking to grow
we know inflation is a very real thing
the cost of living is going to go
up so we need to make sure that our
money's growing not just kick back in a
hammock
so i would tell you this as you look at
your income and what you're planning to
do
work wise if any over the next five to
six years you may have an opportunity
with your
income that you have as opposed moving
or changing your investments
but i want you to do exactly what i just
told a friend of mine to do
in your same spot was to get sit down
with your investment professional
bring in your roth ira bring in your
conventional bringing your 401k
everything and let's get it all on a a
complete game plan
meaning have the dollars all kind of
working together
what's the goal of this what am i
planning to leave what am i planning to
grow
and just get a unified plan for you uh
that way you can start to look and do
you need to back down and be less
aggressive
or do you need to tune up in some areas
it's a better deal to get this holistic
view
rather than a hit or miss thing trying
to jump in and out of the market
ken and i were talking about that at the
break trying to time things in the stock
market
will lead to heartache and headaches and
what we saw as you referenced a moment
ago in 2020 we did see some really big
dips
yeah crazy yeah we did we also saw it
come back that's right
and so this idea of well oh it's going
to crash it can't keep being overheated
and all this kind of stuff nobody has a
crystal ball
stay on the rollercoaster stay focused
put her seat belt on that's called
having a plan yeah i love it good stuff
all right he is chris hogan i'm ken
coleman we're sitting in
uh here on the dave ramsey show more of
your calls coming right up don't move
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff was diagnosed with heart
disease
it was just such a relief to know that
financial burden
was going to be taken care of chm is the
original and longest serving health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
so
the dave ramsey show continues taking
your calls
your questions and we're going to inject
some
clear steps
and some hope and we're gonna cheer you
on i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague chris hogan and
uh it's always fun big man to
to get in here and just meet people
where they are
real life conversations we've all been
there yeah we have there's no shame in
your game nope
reach out especially when you're trying
to get better yeah you know
and so the most important thing is not
to do it alone
yeah reach out get some guidance get
some encouragement get some coaching
or maybe even get a little kick in the
pants
if necessary right that's part of
coaching and coleman you're the career
coach yeah i'm the money coach yeah we
coach people
yeah you know i like that you know the
old kick in the pants is good as long as
you get a little pat on the back too
that's right come on it's got to be well
intended yeah right
and so we got we got to make sure hey we
got to push because what's crazy is
is that you know when you have goals and
you have things that really matter to
you
one of the things i talked about on my
show well the chris hogan show was
not it's really easy to set a goal but i
want to take it a step further you can
go check it out on youtube you can see
it it was one of my first of the year
episodes but what i said was is i gave a
new spin on it we got to not only
identify what we want
but let's think about who stands to gain
like when you have
that that mindset of what you want to
accomplish who stands to gain in your
family if you reach that goal
then let's take it a step further what
are you willing to sacrifice
to get to that goal see we have this and
mentality in our culture today
i want to do this and do that well hold
on
can't do everything so if i do this then
what
or what am i willing to give up am i
willing to watch a little less tv
to start to work on this dream job or
this side gig
or to attack debt and so it's these
little things that we we can do can to
really help promote
our goals and to promote ourselves by
the way i'll make sure i promote
all you gotta do is go to youtube search
the chris hogan show while you're there
search the ken coleman show subscribe to
both of them yep we're gonna coach you
up
but you know i want to add something you
said there because it's absolutely true
and i've found this in my life chris
that i finally started getting
breakthrough in multiple areas of my
life
when i grasp the concept of of the long
haul
and let me explain by that if i went out
on the street let's
say i took a camera with me and a
microphone and i walked around the
street and i just got a bunch of
strangers and i said hey let me let me
ask you this um if i guaranteed you
success in whatever area of their life
all right let's just say crazy i
guarantee you your dream job
would you do whatever it takes what do
you think nine out of 10 people would
say to me oh yeah they would say yes
all right what if i then followed up and
said okay great uh one more question
are you willing to wait as long as it
takes what do you think the answer would
be there no
i think it'd be a lot of pauses oh yeah
because see therein lies
a little bit of what you're touching on
and i just wanted to add to this
anything worth having you're going to
have to be
willing to wait yes now
don't misunderstand what i'm saying i'm
not saying that you're just sitting
around waiting for it to happen a lot of
people just waiting for their lucky
break i'm saying
i am getting up and i am persisting rice
and beans beans and rice that snow ball
you know in in my lane over here we're
talking about well we're gonna
get qualified we're gonna do what it
takes and it's gonna take some time
maybe it takes three to five years to
get qualified in my journey
it took seven years to get to the
opportunity to then
get the dream job so what i want people
to understand is the game changer is i'm
willing to do whatever it takes and
everybody's up for that
we're all fired up when you realize are
you willing to do it
for three years for five years yeah
for seven years are you willing to wait
on the results so i gotta get out there
and i gotta chop wood
and when i'm chopping a big old tree
down chris it ain't gonna happen in an
hour no
i'm telling you this might not happen in
an afternoon no because that tree is go
it's been there a while it's taken some
effort
but here's what i figured out in waiting
there's wisdom and waiting yes
and there's also working and waiting and
i like that you said that it's not just
sitting still
i'm moving in a direction and i can
remember back way back in the day when i
was in mainstream banking
and i knew that wasn't for me i knew i
didn't i didn't like
pitching people products and stuff i
wanted to help people
and so there was two to three years of
that frustration and irritation
before i moved into the next realm and
so
what i would encourage people to do is
let that frustration and irritation
be a motivator for you yeah instead of a
frustrator yeah and i think that
that that can help because where you are
right now doesn't have to be where you
end up that's it
unless you stop persistence is is is
real yeah it's got to sizzle factor we
all like those persistent stories but
nobody ever really talks about the
patience while
persistent yeah and so that's the point
here grab that grab the importance of
patience some of you are
early on in this journey and you're
going come on man
seriously how long is this going to take
well i don't know but i know that you're
going to have to be patient
while you persist you have to you have
to sacrifice but keep that mindset
and understand that it is the patience
that will end up
fueling the persistence well and also as
you have to wait to get to something
you will not you will savor it once you
get there
isn't that the truth you will look at it
totally different as opposed to
if you got it three or four years
earlier you may not have even
appreciated it as much
it's so weird if i start running right
now around the block
and you show up within the first 30
seconds of a bottle of water
i'm grateful oh yeah but i don't
appreciate that bottled water unless you
let me run a mile or two then show up
with the water now how much do i love
that water
you really appreciate that water yeah so
there you go folks all right let's get
to the phones hunter is up in santa cruz
california hunter how can we help
hi guys thank you so much for having me
on the show you bet how can we help
all right so um my wife and i are on
um baby step three and we have about
thirty five hundred dollars in our
emergency fund so
almost almost halfway um but as we get
closer i keep
wondering about uh retirement and i have
a
um roth ira target retirement um
but i was reading that you guys that
dave was saying that the
normal roth ira is better you get better
returns and so i want to do everything i
can to
um hey hunter do you do me a quick favor
let's see if we can
adjust that phone get it close to your
mouth and see if we can hear you a
little bit better
is this better we'll try it chris you
can take over yeah go right ahead
so hunter what you're talking about with
target date funds
these these these funds are essentially
set up
to auto invest for you based on your age
and here's the problem with that my
first book retire inspired i'm gonna
send you one
zack's gonna get your information and
we'll get it to you but i said in that
the subtitle that book is retirement's
not an age it's a financial number
so target date funds are set up to auto
invest based on age as you get older it
gets much more conservative
so i don't like those i'd rather you
utilize the growth stock mutual funds
that we talk about
so that way you are controlling the
growth you're controlling the mindset
of where you are now hear me you're not
there yet because you're still working
on your emergency fund
but i appreciate and respect the fact
that you're kind of peaking ahead
you're getting motivated you you've got
dreams you're trying to chase down
so but but i want you to sit down with
the smart investor pro look at gross
stock mutual funds
diversify across the fore and and truly
start to be intentional
couple things for you go over to
chrishogan360.com i've got a free
investing
guide an everyday millionaire investing
guide at my website
it's a 35 page pdf it's free that you
can download and you and your wife can
start looking at that and start reading
through it
preparing to sit down with the smart
vester pro but i also want you guys to
do the retire inspire quotient the riq
this is gonna show you
really how much you're gonna need to
live the dream but here's what i love
it helps you with the dream date so you
guys can walk through and start to
really uncover
what is retirement gonna look like for
you what are you guys wanting to do
later in life what motivates you what
gets you excited
and it's going to help you guys unite on
the plan
and so that's the route to go uh you
don't ever want to set it and forget it
mentality with investing
you want something that's active and it
is connected for you
and your dreams you know chris this
highlights uh the the reason why we
believe so much in our smartvestor pros
when you've got these
super you know customized plans that
need to be developed based on you know
the progress
you've made financially plus your your
age group that's right you know there's
a lot there you know i just had a friend
of mine
he had his parents come to me and said
hey my parents they're in good shape we
think but we just i said you know what
where do they live and we got a couple
smartmaster pros to talk with them they
pick the one that they like the most i
just really want to
underscore why we actually have that
program that's right you want to remove
the question right there's so many
questions in life and things
you want to work with the pro that's
going to help you get there yep so
daveramsey.com smart investor pros uh
sit down with somebody
uh interview multiple yep multiple
people
get a good feel about it you're hiring
them not the other way around don't be
intimidated
keep asking questions it's kind of like
that kid you know if they get frustrated
with all them questions check them off
the list
keep on asking questions so you get the
answers that you need all right that's
good
speaking of questions we're gonna take
more of yours coming up next don't move
chris hogan kid coleman here on the dave
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague chris
hogan as we take your questions
about your life and your money and your
work triple a 825-5225
today's scripture philippians 4 6
and 7. do not be anxious about anything
but in everything by prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving
let your requests be made known to god
in the peace of god which surpasses all
understanding will guard your hearts and
your minds in christ jesus
our quote today from zappos founder tony
shea
we must all learn not only to not
fear change but to embrace it
enthusiastically
and perhaps even more important
encourage
and drive it triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to jump
in let's go to robin
who joins us in lexington kentucky robin
how can we help hi um
the guy you talked to about an hour ago
was his wife
and has been being separate incomes okay
well i'm kind of in that way
and my husband's on disability social
security is
not just ssi and two children
so with the government with that i can't
work they won't let me work
because they'll take his check so um
i mean i've got student loans i've got
over
118 000 in student loans i've got a
master's degree
and we're finance company we're upon and
everything just to make buy
it's what the 15th of the month and
we are broke what did you get your
master's
what did you get your master's degree in
and and for what purpose
um well i got my master's degree in
ministry
um i was wanting to go to the mission
field but you know financially that's
not working out okay
which i know most missionaries start out
because i'm from a missionary family
start out with nothing anyway how much
is your husband's how much
how much is your husband's disability
check what's that what's that
income the net coming in each month it
is it is
79 793
okay and my and the two kids are 7.93
so we have sales will be fun within four
years
so we have three payments of 793 a month
coming in that just started
the raise in january yes okay and that's
the only income you guys have coming in
the only income okay you know
my house is paid off i paid that with
the first stimulus i do not get the
second student list because i didn't
file in 19.
okay and so you have the student loan
debt of 118 000 what other debts do you
all have
um well we've got things that are all in
pawn
um we have a finance company
um i have um
we have another finance company which
you just
like cash express i don't know if you
know about that or not
i do so i do that so
um and we are we are
postponing like whatever electric bill
we're just making payments to keep it on
my water bill because of a leak was over
almost 300
this month so where if you guys are
bringing in
right now around twenty four hundred
dollars where is it going
well i only have the two checks he only
pays the finance company
and i don't know what he does with his
money
okay so you guys are are operating
what's in uh
divided money yeah okay
okay how long have you all been married
robin
it'd be 20 years next month okay is this
the way it's always been
no uh we we started out working until
he got sick and got cancer twice and
some
health problems happened okay all right
well in looking at this i mean how old
are your kids
and the ones that are on disability or
of we have three that are still well one
is six and get married um
she'll be 18 next month i've got a 14
and a 15 year old better
no deuces from disability okay well i
i can i can say this you know the the
one of the most important things for you
all to do
with limited income right now is to
absolutely be on a plan
and these finance companies i'm going to
tell you right now those things
are eating away and the charges and you
know
you got to get this cobweb off of you
and you guys aren't going to be able to
do this working independently
you're going to have to sit down and
come together and that's talking about
putting your money in a joint account
together a bill paying account
and really starting to dig in and look
at this um
this is i've tried that he just he just
doesn't want to do that
okay are you all you've been married
before and it's
not the there's no trust or financial
needs just he won't do it right well you
guys been together 20 years
okay so i don't know what happened in
the previous time and and and
that ain't your fault i'm going to tell
you right now um
and so you know are you all plugged into
a church at all
yes i am um he isn't now okay we're in a
very small search
i'm really not in lexington i'm
outskirts of mexico i'm more close to
tennessee ryan
okay and and you look at mccree county
where the poorest in the combination so
i live
in a very small hey robin robin i i i
you know listen i can i shoot you really
really straight here and and i'm gonna
try to say this as lovingly as i can
but you are you in some ways are victim
of really bad
government policy and i can't stand when
when i hear
calls like this that you know if i go to
work
he loses his disability um and i don't
know what's going on with the kids
we don't really have time to break that
down but i think you're gonna have to
also consider
how much money could you make if you
worked a full-time job
and what would you now i did have a job
about three years ago
okay how much were you bringing home
what was your net
i was bringing home not exactly
give me a ball give me a ballpark
segment bring in about
maybe about a thousand to two thousand a
month okay
that's that's always that worked at
walmart so as a full-time employee at
work
great but here's my point your full time
at walmart and if you had to for a
season
you could work a second job beyond that
and if you got that take home to 2 500
or 3 000 a month
you're coming out in the positive i'm
telling you you
have got to get back to full-time work
and this puts the pressure on the hubs
to kind of come together here and we go
hey look
we cannot keep taking disability
payments right and trying to live off of
that you cannot
do this anymore robin you got to go out
and work
your tail off and when you do that this
is america
and i'm sure in kentucky and tennessee
there's plenty of jobs
you can get out there and make a
substantial
amount more than even if we lost those
disability payments and go
who cares but we're free from the
shackles because right now
you're limited i'm pretty fired up robin
robin you need to go get a job
and i mean like another job and no no
listen
i could go back to walmart they would
hire me back in heart because i left it
did i'm hanging up on you
yeah right now because you need to get
in the car and you need to go get a job
and you need to play this back for the
husband and hubs listen to me hubs
i'm shooting you straight hubs 20 years
you've been married to this woman
you're full of crap sir you don't have
trust problems
you have discipline problems and you
don't want to own up to it and so you're
leaning on a crutch from a previous
relationship
that was 20 years ago let it go bro
let it go and step up and i know you've
had health problems and i don't begrudge
you for that
but you can still be a man
and own this problem with your wife
and take care of this take care of your
kids take care of them
and i got to tell you well you know what
because this is
this is wrong yeah no and it's a
systemic problem this is a systemic
problem it's a government benefits
problem where it
motivates and disincentivizes people to
be free but here's the other thing
this dude has no excuse to not do joint
bank accounts and sit down with her
and go i'm going to stop spending my
benefits check however i please because
i'm so
freaking miserable that it's my excuse
i'm gonna tell you something
you better take over no you're good dude
cause my blood because
it's wrong it's it's wrong i see your
neck getting red you're getting feisty
i hope he watches it robin you better
play it back for him
because i'll be the bad guy yeah all
right we got to help people all right
that was coaching
yeah yeah there's the kick in the pants
you know pat on the back there
all right hey uh i want to say uh love
you bro i appreciate you
always fun hanging with my friend chris
hogan i want to thank our
producer james childs zach bennett
sitting in today uh associate producing
call screening thank you zach
but most of all thank you america for
listening this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
you